do you think you have what it takes
to work here
if you are interested and you're serious
and you believe you have the talent then
pay attention watch this whole video and
please follow the instructions cause
it's gonna get real
we're looking to hire two types of
people we're looking to hire an editor
slash filmmaker type we're looking to
hire another visual effects artist we're
going to have uncut footage from an
unreleased segment of one of our
corridor crew videos and we'll have that
available to download and you will need
to take that and edit it and make it a
final polished version now if you're a
visual effects artist it's a little bit
different we're just going to be looking
for a reel and some pictures and a name
and that's it ideally if you're
submitting a reel it should be comprised
of shots you have basically completed by
yourself or at least have done the
majority of the work in that shot i just
want to put out there this is not an
internship level job this is not your
very first edit your very first 3d
animation this is something that you
should have some experience in it
doesn't mean you need to be like you
know 15 years experience in the industry
it's just the work you do has to be
decent ideally with our creative brains
we're all refining each other's work but
needs to go online it needs to entertain
and wow people one thing is that we look
for people who are very self-driven
every single person here at the studio
knows how to do something special but
they also are interested in other areas
that aren't their expertise we're all
hungry for knowledge we're all ready to
experiment and learn new things and i
mean that's really what creates the
content that you see you have to be the
type of person who understands what a
deadline is and set it for yourself and
follow it and i mean that with 100
absolute clarity even if they weren't
working here they just won't be able to
help themselves they'd have to be making
things that's the kind of person that
would fit well here at corridor what are
the perks the benefits
members only benefits myth number one at
working at corridor is that we goof
around all the time and are always
having fun we're actually sitting at our
desk quietly working most of the time
but we are always having fun so yes
benefits uh you get to play smash
brothers with some of the best players
in the entire
world i don't know we got
snacks another myth is you always have
to be on camera you don't have to be on
camera if you are camera shy it's
totally cool yeah if you are good on
camera awesome well let's just be honest
though a lot of what we do isn't just
about the end result it's about the
process and we follow
the artists through that process for so
many of these videos i mean literally
every video that goes on the crew
channel so yeah just just be aware that
you might be responsible for inspiring
the next generation of filmmakers
couple parameters to make sure that we
can even hire you in the first place
this is a global submission we're
fortunate enough to bring in fener uh
last year who was canadian it was our
first international hire there was a
process for that but it is totally
doable the visa process for overseas
work visas is a lot more stringent
requiring you to be a much more i guess
prolific artist in your work it's up to
interpretation but just be aware you
also got to move to la yes
yes you do need to be willing to move to
los angeles and work out of our studio
that is a requirement dory la's cool
it's not as bad as everybody says it is
it's actually a beautiful city
it is a beautiful city it's got a bunch
of beautiful pockets and uh it's rich in
culture
if you're an enjoyer of culture you'll
love it here
there we go let's get into the fun part
if you are an editor submission download
the footage that is in the description
of this video there'll be a big link use
that as your raw footage cut that
footage together into the best possible
video you can make then upload it to
youtube and send it to us via email in
the subject line of that email put your
name followed by editor submission in
the body of that email put your name
with the youtube link that's it follow
those instructions exactly if you don't
it's instantly disregarded details
matter here at corridor when you're
uploading things online you have to put
links in the description for brands etc
details matter let's say i like to mess
around with vfx oh and i want to apply
now what do i do sam another great
question so glad you asked if you're
interested in applying for the visual
effects submission put your name in the
subject of the email followed by vfx
submission in the body of the email put
your name again with a link to your reel
and then attach up to three still images
of your work i'm just gonna say those
still images are very important you
should make sure that they are some of
the coolest images you have created
because we're going to get a lot of
submissions we're going to get hundreds
maybe even thousands of submissions and
we're going to go through each and every
one so it's very important to make a
really big impression hey i got a tip
for you all your vfx submission people
out there hey if you have some personal
work in there it's kind of cool because
it shows us what your actual personal
passions are so yeah includes that
personal work too it's going to be
really hard for us to get back to
everybody last time we did this process
we had over a thousand submissions for
the editor position so what we're going
to do is the day that this video drops
there's going to be a three week window
at the end of that three week window
submissions will be officially closed
that way everyone has a fair chance if
you've got work or you've got other
things going on please follow those
instructions and remember we just get a
ton of submissions so if you don't hear
back from us within you know probably
three months after the release of the
video i'm sorry that means you probably
didn't get considered for round two and
we have multiple rounds after this it's
been incredibly humbling to see how many
people applied in the past that we've
done this and i'm sure we'll get
hundreds if not a thousand or more
submissions here and it will be just as
humbling now so to all of you out there
who are
making art making films making cool
stuff thank you i appreciate each and
every one of you that applies for this
i'm sorry we can't hire every single
person but i wish you all luck and
i can't wait to see what happens if you
uh win there will be a cash prize
every two weeks you will be rewarded
with a cash prize for your submission so
once again in the description of this
video there are directions on how to do
each submission as well as the link to
the raw footage good luck and thank you
for watching the videos and hope to see
you here yeah the roaches have
been subdued
i would call it hardly a roach problem i
hardly see one these days everyone gets
fused at the hip after the show's done
because they've been rubbing thighs all
day
okay good